Fair Lord Moylan the former advisor to
Boris Johnson Lord welcome to you I mean
the the consensus seems to be emerging
that actually Richard Sharp whatever he
did wrong with inadvertence he's acted
with Integrity by going in the way that
he has done isn't this just really
evidence that anyone you know who comes
into Boris Johnson ultimately their
reputation gets contaminated
my reputation hasn't been contaminated
I'd give you a list of uh at least a
hundred people who've worked with um
Boris Johnson whose reputation I know
from personal knowledge hasn't been
contaminated
um I think that's a Preposterous thing
to say that this was a small
administrative error I think Mr Sharp
whom I don't know uh and and of course I
haven't read the report in full because
it's only just been published so with
those caveats uh Mr Sharp appears to
have uh disclosed what might be a
conflict of interest to the cabinet
secretary and thought that he was
fulfilling the rules by doing that it's
been found that he didn't fulfill the
rules by doing that that wasn't quite
enough and and very honorably I think
we've all agreed he stood down
um as a result of being found to have
made that modest breach I don't actually
see how this engages Boris Johnson at
all actually
well it does because Boris Johnson it
was his financial difficulties and the
fact that he needed to go back in
history you could say well what was the
interest of the the question that's
issue here was did Mr Sharp have an
interest that he should have declared to
the panel it doesn't matter what the
history of that interest was and what
he's been found out
um what it's been said of him is that he
should have declared it he thought he'd
done that effectively all right model
model
um and nobody thinks he was being
dishonest at all
um he thought he had declared it doesn't
matter what it was it could have been
his grandmother's interest in azaleas if
it was relevant to the job I don't see
what it really why there's any need to
bring Boris Johnson into this at all
because Boris Johnson in late 2020
needed a loan of 800 000 pounds I mean
that's not Richard Sharp's fault
well
all right as I say you can go into the
history of what led to the conflict of
interest that's not about what today's
report is about what today's report
about is did he have a conflict of
interest which he should have declared
and it was found that he didn't and he's
behaved very responsibly in going
although uh that is he didn't declare it
although he thought he had and and
that's really as far as I can tell is
the is the long and the short of this
whole uh quite expensive report
um so there was a conflict of interest
and it was to do with Boris the idea
that everybody's reputation you know
who's connected with Boris is destroyed
um it is complete nonsense or this isn't
even really a story about Boris there
are stories there are things you might
want to ask about Boris and finances I
don't know the answers to them they've
got nothing to do with Richard Sharp or
the BBC
well a lot more than that apologies for
any uh imputation on that suggested that
your reputation was tarnished well
that's very very kind I mean you seem to
be suggesting straight off that my
reputation had been tarnished why would
why would you have me on your show if I
had such a bad reputation no absolutely
no we're not implying uh there's been
any damage but it but it is a fact
nonetheless that a lot of people who do
come into Boris Johnson into contact
with him their reputation ends up being
damaged in some way and Richard Sharp is
really the latest example of that well
maybe that's because the there are
people in Britain who want to eradicate
Boris Johnson's memory and they go for
people near him
um very much as you have these attacks
on Trump at the moment to
um in in America I'm not saying there's
any similarity between Trump and Boris
because five minutes intelligent
reflection shows that there isn't but
it's simply a technique that seems to be
growing particularly on the left is to
use quartz and smears and so on to keep
going at somebody even after they've
stood down
a little morning before I let you go I
mean this really does appear to be the
job from hell I mean you're in the
political Spotlight throughout uh who on
Earth would want this job who on Earth
would want to succeed Richard Sharp
I think it's a really really good
question and I don't think it's just BBC
jobs I think these high-profile
chairmanships where you get somebody who
has real business experience who doesn't
come from a political background who
isn't used to being abused on Twitter
the whole time and whatever but they
come out of a a world of business and
finance experience and they have a lot
to give
in these roles
and then they discover the sort of
battering they get and the publicity
they've been subjected to not just
Richard Sharp I think of other people
there as the man who was chairing the
the environment agency at the time of
the uh flooding and the um uh in the
dump in the somerset levels
um whose reputation was totally trash
because he was on his Christmas holiday
who's a very senior and significant
engineer who'd taken that job I I think
it's really difficult to persuade people
to do it
um because of the potential for exposure
and having your whole family laughed at
and and having your reputation ridiculed
not because you've done a bad job but
because of some something related to a
headline you never dare take a holiday
because if something goes wrong and
you're photographed on a beach you're
sort of trashed
um so I think it really is difficult but
I think it's really important for the
BBC to have somebody as chairman who is
their friend in government you know
people write about this as if the if a
conservative comes in anywhere into the
Ambit of the BBC Administration they're
there as a sort of Attila the Hun coming
to destroy it whereas nearly all of them
actually are are there to be the BBC's
they they turn out to be the BBC's
friend at the heart of government and if
you cut yourself off completely to into
a holy political sphere you won't have
any friends of past government yeah Lord
Moylan greatly appreciate you joining me
this morning thank you thank you very
much here